as i spend some time at home with my
family this christmas season i'm
reminded yet again how quickly time
flies it's the end of the year again not
really sure how that happened but
naturally it gets me thinking about the
year i just had and whether or not i
liked that year what are some things
that i did well what are some things
that i want to improve on and do i
really like the direction that my life
is going in and for the most part
probably more than any other late
december pondering that answer is yes
you know i'm i'm pretty happy with where
i'm at right now but it wasn't easy to
get here and i remember so many times in
my life where that answer was no
where i really didn't like the person
that i was when i thought about it i
really had some deep regrets about the
year that i just had
i made some mistakes that i really
wanted to correct i wanted to break some
bad habits i wanted to start new habits
but the problem is it seemed like the
same story every year i didn't really
know where to start i didn't really know
the secret to getting change to stick
and i'd watch youtube videos just like
this one trying to figure out you know
the magic formula that will help me
stick to my goals and truly start a new
chapter in my life but the bottom line
is you're not going to change a thing if
you don't want to change if you just
feel like you should make a new year's
resolution or you want to change some
aspect of your life because somebody
told you that it was a good idea then
you kind of defeat yourself before you
even start you need to combine a very
strong will to change with a good
strategy and i can't provide you with
that will
but i can provide you with a strategy so
in this video i want to cover some
things that helped me really transform
my life you know not in sort of an
overnight kind of way as we'll go over
but as a consistent mechanism that
served me day after day so that over the
course of months i was in a better
position than i was the previous year
and these things that i'm gonna go over
don't just apply to new year's you know
you might be watching this video in july
it doesn't really matter if you have a
strong feeling that there's something in
particular that you want to change about
your life then hopefully some of these
things that i'm going to go over will
help you do just that so the first thing
is to pick one thing to focus on it's
extremely tempting to try to you know
let your mind run irresponsibly wild
with all the things that you want to
change about your life in your mental
health your physical health your social
life blah blah blah and this is good
this motivation and this drive to
improve is extremely useful but you
should dedicate all of this emotion to
changing one thing about your life you
know later down the line as this thing
becomes a habit you know it might only
take 30 days for you to have this thing
locked in then you can think about
adding more things so what thing do you
pick well i think the first thing you
should do is write down a list of things
that you want to change about your life
in several different areas and be very
detailed and specific where do you want
to be five years from now you know where
do you want to be in your financial life
your social life what do you want your
mental health to be like be very
specific about this and detailed and if
you were to boil down one of these
things into a daily habit that you could
implement what would that look like an
obvious example is if you want to have
some you know ripped beach body and have
crazy muscle mass and low body fat then
obviously probably the most important
thing that will help you get there is to
develop a consistent gym habit so the
actionable process to achieve that
hypothetical goal is to go to the gym
four or five times a week or whatever
you think works for you and once you've
determined what the actionable process
to achieve that eventual goal is it's
really important to reflect on whether
or not you are comfortable with doing
that process day after day after day is
this something that is realistic to you
is this something that you think you
could stick to because this process is
what you're going to be interacting with
100 of the time you're not going to be
interacting with the goal you know once
you get there your goal will change the
process itself is what that thing will
feel like it'll never feel like you are
you know living that goal you know what
i'm saying you have to learn to fall in
love with the process itself and that is
possible because a lot of that
satisfaction comes from the quiet
understanding that you're trending your
life in the direction that you want to
trend it in part of the reason why going
to the gym feels so good is because you
know that going to the gym is good for
you and by going to the gym you're
becoming someone you're proud of you're
operating on a day-to-day basis as a
more authentic version of yourself and
the gym specifically feels really good
because of the endorphin rush and the
feeling of power you get when you lift
heavy weights you know that's a bonus
pretty much anybody who's ever been
consistent with a gym knows that they're
consistent not because they're thinking
about this end goal all the time it's
just because they really like the way
going to the gym makes them feel both
physically and mentally and emotionally
it's just so it's just so good for you
this is a big ad for going to the gym if
being well read and well versed in
literature is extremely important to you
and you decide that this is the one
thing that you want to work on you want
to read a book a month or whatever then
anybody who's actually been successful
with that will know that the thing that
kept them going wasn't this vague
concept or this vague sentiment of
getting smarter they just learned to
enjoy reading for what it is you know
the microcosm of their end goal became
the enjoyable thing to interact with so
decide what exactly about your life you
want to change you know what does that
look like specifically then determine
what that thing looks like on a
day-to-day basis then try to figure out
whether or not you're ready to strap on
the boots and do that thing every single
day because that thing is the thing if
you can't find enjoyment and fulfillment
in the daily process of getting to where
you want to be in life then not only are
you probably not going to stick with
this change but you're overall just
going to live a less enjoyable life you
know if everything you do on a
day-to-day basis is just a means to an
end then your life is just a means to an
end alright the second point i want to
make is that forcing yourself is a good
thing a lot of the time right off the
bat you might have alarm bells going
joey what about toxic hustle culture
what about getting burnt out this toxic
self-improvement is really taking over
your mind joey but i think that's all bs
to a certain extent almost everything
worthwhile in life requires some form of
sacrifice a lot of the time you're not
going to want to go to the gym a lot of
the time you're not going to want to
read books you're not going to want to
drink more water or whatever the hell
you decided is the best thing for you
but you should never determine the value
that something has in your life before
you do it um not never that i mean
that's probably not a concrete rule like
you shouldn't
you shouldn't just do drugs and then
evaluate afterwards whether it's good
for you or not like you know you can use
your judgment but we're not talking
about doing crack here we're talking
about doing things that you've already
determined are good for you and will
help you be where you want to be in life
and help you be someone you're proud of
and a lot of the times even though these
things are extremely good for you before
you do them you're gonna have tons of
this emotional and physical resistance
in the way of doing that thing and a lot
of the time these rationalizations will
say stuff like you're getting burnt out
you need to just take a break today but
in these particular situations what
you'll find is that almost 100 of the
time if you just do the thing anyways
you'll realize that those
rationalizations were you know
if you're super tired you're super
stressed from work and you have this
voice in your head saying
no you're burnt out just take a break
don't pick up those sneakers and go for
a run but you do it anyways you just go
and put on your sweatpants you put on
your running shoes and you go for a run
anyways pretty much 100 of the time
you'll say wow i'm so glad i didn't
listen to that rationalization i feel
invigorated and proud of myself because
i didn't fall for that and on that topic
of burnout or feeling lethargic or
depressed it's extremely hard to feel
that way by consistently taking
constructive action far more draining on
your will and your existence is the slow
creep of existential dread as you sit
around and do nothing and let
opportunities pass you by that's far
more draining on your existence than
forcing yourself to go to the gym even
though you're a little tired so use your
brain i'm not saying punish yourself for
messing up or you know make your feet
bleed and call yourself a if you
don't run 10 miles and take cold showers
in the morning or you know something
stupid like that obviously you can take
it too far but it is healthy to force
yourself past the resistance and the
rationalizations holding you back from
doing something that you already know is
good for you and the final point i want
to mention is that you can make the
processes work for you there is a way to
make the processes genuinely more
enjoyable and there's a lot of methods
that you can employ to make this happen
it's important to realize that you're on
your own side you know you don't want to
punish yourself for messing up you don't
want to participate in activities that
you find absolutely unenjoyable to your
core
um there are ways to make these things
that are good for you also feel good in
the moment a really good example of this
is i wanted to start doing deadlifts but
i hate deadlifts and i know that
deadlifts are super good for you and
they're one of the most useful compound
exercises you can implement but i do not
find any enjoyment in doing deadlifts
whatsoever i kind of have low back pain
and allegedly dead lifts are supposed to
help your low back pain because you can
strengthen your low back by doing them
but if your low back hurts so much that
you can't do them anyways i don't know
it's always just been a mess for me but
i recently discovered the hex bar and
even though the hex bar is kind of
frowned upon with like
powerlifting purists or whatever who
gives a i tried it and i found it
so much more comfortable to do the lift
i could load up more weight on it the
weight was distributed to my hips and
not to my low back off the initial
pickup and now hex bar deadlifts are a
staple of my back day routine
it's something that i actually look
forward to doing another example is
reading books you know maybe you
actually hate sitting down to read a
book so instead you might want to try
audiobooks this video is not sponsored
by audible by the way you know i've
mentioned habit bunching on this channel
maybe you want to implement a writing
habit every single morning maybe you
create a rule with yourself where you
can't have your first sip of coffee
unless you have written your first
sentence of writing and as you're
writing you get to enjoy this nice hot
cup of coffee do not be afraid to modify
your approach and modify the habit so
that it is something that is more
enjoyable to you and if the process
itself is something that you look
forward to doing then i guarantee you
it'll be no problem sticking with that
change for the long term so the bottom
line is if you want to substantially
change your life in one year take it one
habit at a time figure out why you want
to do that habit and what the end goal
of that habit is then try to make that
habit as enjoyable as possible for
yourself and once you do that do it
anyways regardless of what your
rationalizations are evaluate whether
that thing was good for you after you do
it not before you do it and you can
start compounding this month after month
once you have one habit locked in after
one month add a new habit the second
month and by the end of a year you might
have 12 new habits which might be
overkill at that point you might only
need a few cornerstone habits that will
change your life forever but honestly
over the course of one year the sky is
the limit you can be in a substantially
better place this time next year if you
implement this strategy combined with
your motivation and will to change so
good luck to all of you guys no matter
whether it's new year's or july august
september or whatever whenever you're
watching this video this advice applies
to you i just want to give a big thank
you to anker for sponsoring this video
for those of you who don't know and i'd
be shocked if you don't anker is one of
the best electronics companies i've ever
come across not only is there stuff
usually higher quality than the big name
tech giant companies that are out there
but it's also more affordable and gets
to you faster and they recently sent me
the 623 magnetic wireless charger for my
phone which is one of the most beautiful
phone stands i've ever seen it's shaped
like a little pop can but 40 smaller
comes in a variety of colors it is hefty
weighty and made of premium material and
it's part of their meg go line of
products so if you have an iphone 12 or
later anything with that meg safe
technology on the back then you can just
snap your phone right onto the back of
this charger and the weight of the
premium material on the stand keeps your
phone upright the thing doesn't fall
down and it's just a great beautiful way
to charge your phone without having to
deal with messy cables perfect for your
nightstand or desk or wherever you like
to charge your phone i personally like
to use it on a little shelf next to my
desk so that it's not in my periphery
distracting me from my work so if you're
in the market for a new phone stand
slash charger and you want one that's
made out of high quality materials is
cost effective and gets to you fast then
i have no other recommendation other
than this one i'm super satisfied with
mine you can pick yours up using my link
in the description below and while
you're visiting their site i'd highly
recommend just kind of snooping around
at some of their other products i'm a
big fan of the company and i think more
people should know about them so go
check them out and thanks again anchor
for sponsoring this video and if you
liked this video then make sure you hit
like because when you hit like the
algorithm blesses me and it shoves my
bald head into other people's homepages
helping them out which also helps me out
so it's a win-win for everybody if
you're lurking here consider subscribing
and also checking out the brand new
instagram that i just dropped i'm gonna
do a giveaway on there very soon and
since there's so few followers you have
a very high chance of winning that
giveaway all you have to do is follow so
you don't miss it other than that thank
you so much for watching happy new year
and we'll catch you in the next video
you